bom dia eu vou fazer uma apresentação um
pouquinho sobre a minha experiência
nesses anos no nosso grupo completou 23
anos é 21 anos este ano é de atividade
começou em 96 e quando entrei na
faculdade quando entrei no curso
universitário o que motivava né pra
entrar na universidade era a
oportunidade que a gente tinha é com o
meu pai e químico então sempre motivo
quando era pequeno ea gente ficou é o
que me motivou foi imaginar que a gente
podia né com a caneta só desenvolver
teorias né sensacionais
ou então a gente podia pegar um monte de
sucata um monte de material desenvolveu
os equipamentos modernos e isso que
sempre motivo é só que a realidade do
curso é um pouquinho diferente disso não
é a realidade dos cursos universitários
que a gente tem hoje
elas acabam fazendo com que as pessoas
se distancia desse sonho quando tinha
como a criança não aquelas idéias que a
gente tinha de criança aos poucos vai se
perdendo na conti é pelo sistema que a
gente tem de avaliações não é de até a
forma como a estrutura desses cursos e
aos poucos as pessoas vão perdendo essa
motivação inicial
então acho que o grande desafio é nesse
tempo que a experiência que eu tenho é a
gente tentar resgatar lepra os
estudantes essa oportunidade de
continuarem a sonhar não é continuar a
sonhar e tentar realizar seus sonhos
então o que me motivou a seguir
desenvolvendo projetos na área de
astronomia foram essas imagens aqui para
ouvir essas e mais é essa aí a imagem do
planeta marte que foi tirado em 1986
pela sonda viking né eu tive acesso
naquela época a gente não tinha internet
como a gente tem hoje em dia então meu
acesso a essas imagens foi através do
livro do do conceito cosmos e quando eu
vi essas imagens não acreditava que a
gente estava vendo a imagem de outro
planeta que é mais do planeta marte
naquela época a gente pegar um livro e
poder ver mais o planeta marte então
esse é um dos pontos que mais me motivou
e mostrou que era possível né haja um
ser humano poder tão distante né e
seguir explorando locais distante e esse
aí então aqui em campo sou eu vim pra cá
e 94
a gente criou um clube de astronomia lá
em niterói
eu participava do clube de astronomia
niterói e lá a gente conseguiu realizar
diversas atividades inovadoras usando a
gente faz a nossa imaginação com pouco
recurso ea gente conseguiu é desenvolver
atividades que colocou colocar o nosso
clube no nosso grupo em destaque e
chegou a viajar para fora do país para
fazer apresentações e 94 93 e eu vim pra
cá os 94 e 95 junto com o nosso grupo de
niterói gente veio aqui e começou a
realizar algumas atividades para motivar
e tenta identificar talentos aqui na
cidade pra gente começar um grupo de
astronomia aqui e essa aqui é uma das
primeiras imagens do nosso grupo de
campos
a halita o professor marcomede rangel
nunes aqui o que já é faleceu que sempre
ajudou a gente nos moldes jogador de
deficiência do brasil ea gente foi uma
visita que a gente fez no observatório e
essa questão os primeiros e mais do
nosso grupo que começou como um clube de
astronomia de campos de goytacazes
nesse momento a gente nunca imaginava
que a gente um dia ea chegar até
alcançar o sucesso que alcançou então
vou agora tentar relatar o que fez a
gente
qual o diferencial nosso né a gente tá
aqui está afastado em um grande centro
campos dos goytacazes não é uma capital
de um estado
apesar da importância da cidade ea gente
começou a desenvolver projetos sem
recursos e sem equipamentos a gente
conseguiu um telescópio pequeno que a
gente não tinha equipamento a utilizar
de conseguir um telescópio pequeno em
que foi lá na zona oeste do rio
uma pessoa que estava querendo se
desfazer do equipamento de contas
próprias em pequenininho é bem é simples
e com esses telescópios começou e nas
praças
a gente começou aí na no farol de são
thomé foi
circulando aqui na região levando o
telescópio observação do céu e conseguiu
aos poucos não é motivar outras pessoas
a participar com a gente nessas
atividades e o grupo começou a crescer
dança aqui a gente começou já a realizar
diversas atividades o público foi
aumentando à medida que a gente
realizando as atividades ea gente
começou a já a fazer grandes eventos
aqui são eventos mais recentes mas os
público o público foi crescendo a cada
evento que a gente ia fazendo no dia e
atividade simples que é colocar o
telescópio em praça para observação de
um grupo então a gente realizou diversas
atividades nessa forma essa foi uma das
maiores que a gente fez tinha milhares
de pessoas observando com a gente na
praça são salvador que luciano de campos
e todas essas atividades abrindo portas
para a gente no mundo nessa atividade
que foi realizada aqui em campos que a
gente imagina que está fazendo um
projeto que está no local um pouco mais
afastado que as pessoas não têm
conhecimento a ser desenvolvido mas a
gente tudo que a gente fez aqui acabou
tendo alcance mundial ea gente passou a
representar vários grupos internacionais
que eu nunca imaginei que fosse
acontecer é um grupo aqui na cidade de
campos não a gente passou a representar
até parcerias com vários grupos no mundo
a gente coordena projetos um projeto da
nasa no brasil estamos ser campeão
diverso grupo internacional a gente
representa no brasil mas aqui é o
símbolo do nosso grupo de astronomia que
engloba é um grupo de voluntários que
envolve pessoas de várias instituições
diferentes não estudantes professores e
público em geral ea gente a partir daí
virou oportunidade junto com o que a
gente vinha fazendo de trazer pessoas
aqui pra cidade que nosso objetivo era
que as pessoas pudessem comparar o que a
gente estava desenvolvendo como estava
sendo desenvolvido em outros locais que
só para comparação as pessoas tenham
acesso a o que está sendo feito em
campos o primeiro evento quem organizou
foi 98 ea partir daí todo ano a gente
realiza diversos eventos aqui na cidade
esse aqui mostra
a quantidade como foi crescendo a
realização desses eventos
isso aqui é um dos que esses são os
últimos eventos que está realizando
então a gente conseguiu dessa forma a
motivar várias pessoas lá e trazer
pessoas de diversos locais do mundo e do
brasil pra cá a gente não tem mais louco
isso fosse acontecer e junto com isso a
gente também conseguiu alguns destaques
em campanhas descoberta de asteróides e
diversas outras atividades que a gente
fez mas é o vendo o resultado não é
parece que as organizações e tudo é
muito simples né
na verdade cada organização dessa sem
recursos não era muito difícil a gente
contou com o apoio de muita gente para
poder conseguir realizar boa vontade
muitas pessoas né e aconteceram vários
fatos né que a gente pensava assim dessa
vez a gente não vai conseguir fazer né a
gente imaginava e sonhava e tentava
organizar até tem até um relato que eu
acho que é interessante mostrar como é
às vezes é difícil a organização do
agente a organizar um dos eventos uma
das pessoas que eu não vou dar a
informação é assim tão precisos mais ela
é a pessoa que estava com dificuldade a
gente não estava conseguindo recursos
para essa pessoa vir e uma das
dificuldades maiores a traseira do rio
para a capital no avião para trazer
porque a pessoa é um destaque
internacional é a prova desse avião e
quando chegou na véspera a gente não
tinha transporte para trazê la pampa
então então praticamente impossível já
estava com a passagem pra vir pro brasil
mas não tinha como fazer para campos que
estava em um avião para trazer do rio
para campos não tinha o vôo no horário
então ele só precisa que só podia ficar
um dia aqui eu não estou nada famoso e
aí a gente pediu auxílio a várias
pessoas uma oportunidade foi na rádio né
na época o programa do jô ribeiro jorge
de olho na cidade e na rádio pedir ajuda
eu fui lá e pediu foi não tem jeito a
gente precisa trazer o aço nota a gente
não consegue se alguém tinha um avião
para emprestar uma coisa que parecia
impossível e não passou acho que meia
hora depois uma hora recebeu um
telefonema de uma pessoa me dando um
contato na aeronáutica e que é renault
que ajudar a gente
então o que parecia que era impossível
foi resolvido ea gente estava tentando
isso há muito tempo e isso é resolvido
naquele momento então é por isso que é a
gente eu aprendi é que a gente não deve
nunca desistir
então a gente pode insistir que a gente
vai sempre conseguir né algum possível
vai ter a oportunidade de tentar
realizar os sonhos ea e as mudanças
estão ocorrendo a gente antes não tinha
muito recurso tecnológico agora tem
novos recursos tecnológicos esse recurso
tecnológico auxiliou a gente por exemplo
poder realizar eventos e como está
acontecendo agora quem está vendo a
transmissão ao vivo do evento pela
internet então tem um público maior se
sentindo esses eventos pela internet por
outros locais então essa maravilha que
tem um teste agora é poder proporcionar
que a gente tem um também ou transmissão
virtual isso também chegou à astronomia
e chegou para as outras áreas que a
gente faz na ciência
então eu parece muito mas só que a
chegada desses recursos
às vezes elas criam uma necessidade
imediata mas logo depois a necessidade
imediata faz com que a gente volte ao
quem estava fazendo antes tenta adaptar
aquelas tecnologias ao nosso pensamento
antigo então é necessário também uma
nova forma de pensar quando chega às
suas tecnologias
então é um tem um livro que eu gosto
muito que o falcão maltês do das chamas
que é aquele padrão de romance policial
moderna que a gente tem e tem um trecho
do livro que vou só eu uso nem como
referência pra isso que a história do
psd um detetive que foi chamado por uma
senhora para poder investigar é o que
estava acontecendo com o marido dela que
tinha desaparecido há cinco anos o
marido dela fazia tudo regrada
sim segunda feira no porto e terça feira
jogar futebol quarta-feira em um cinema
e tal aí chegou um dia de repente
desapareceu e sumiu e ela sobre cinco
anos depois que estava em outra cidade
aí quando eles foram o detetive para
investigar e nessa outra cidade
realmente era ele que estava lá e ela
ele foi perguntar o que tinha acontecido
porque a esposa dele falou que a vida
dela ele tem ele tinha recurso e deixou
tudo então eu só queria saber o que
estava acontecendo por de repente eles
sumiram desaparecer né e é o que o foi
assim disse que estava saindo do
trabalho fazer aquela vida regrada de
repente quando ele passou na rua quer um
andaime no lado dele a imaginou se
tivesse caído em cima de mim eu teria
morrido mas resolveu repensar a vida
dele todinha e foi para a cidade
só que depois viu que nessa outra cidade
acontecia tudo da mesma forma em caso de
novo segunda-feira em campo pouco
terça-feira futebol quarta feira o
flamengo então basicamente o que
acontece com a gente né
quando chega esse recurso todos
tecnológico tem um impacto inicial
a tendência na guiné em breve é fazer
poder ter essa oportunidade de fazer
essas viagens agora conhecer mais e mais
detalhes de outros astros do universo
lançaria ea gente é possível a gente
está tentando agora aqui realizar nosso
objetivo de poder sair da terra um
pouquinho com equipamentos nosso saque e
esse é um sonho que a gente espera em
breve poder realizar
e tudo isso é no desenvolvimento todas
essas coisas a gente sempre esquece às
vezes comete relata esses casos que a
gente de sucesso dificuldade é que está
relacionada também com a nossa vida
cotidiana
então a nossa vida cotidiana também
afeta tudo isso que a gente está
tentando realizar
então às vezes as operações que são
necessários são também as operações
sobre a questão de problemas
particulares dificuldades que surgem no
nosso cotidiano então várias
dificuldades surgem nesse caminhos mas
mesmo assim a gente sempre consegue
apoio nem quando se tem uma perspectiva
sempre a gente consegue algum apoio para
realizar esse objetivo então ninguém
deve desistir dos seus sonhos seguir
adiante né pra gente eu posso falar eu
falo a gente porque
grupo né eu só falo mais vezes mas é um
grupo de várias pessoas que já passaram
nesses 21 anos e chegamos a um ponto em
que a gente alcançou destaque
internacional
nós somos um dos grupos mais ativos do
mundo na nossa área e que começou há 21
anos a gente nunca imaginando que
aconteceria o encontro com o apoio de
várias pessoas
e a gente tem sempre às vezes questões
pessoais que podem fazer com que a gente
tenha uma dificuldade disse que é meu
pai teve um acidente muito sério há seis
anos não é completa em agosto agora seis
anos que ficou totalmente independente
agora de um avc hemorrágico grave não
faz com que a gente tivesse eu
particularmente tive que me afastar
durante um período para ficar com ele no
hospital e aí ó eu pensei que neste
momento não conseguimos fazer nada
porque eu tive que ficar diariamente no
hospital acompanhando
foram meses de acompanhamento e aí eu
descobri é como a tecnologia pode ajudar
a gente consiga continuar aí consegui
continuar desenvolvendo projetos é mesmo
não estando presente fisicamente né
através de uso das novas tecnologias
então as tecnologias também podem ser
essas novas tecnologias um grande apoio
para a gente para desenvolver novos
projetos e tentar realizar nossos sonhos
então obrigado
[Aplausos]